بينضم الينا في هذا اللقاء سيد سام وربورغ
المتحدث الرسمي الاقليمي باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وبالتاكيد سنتحدث معه
عن كواليس قمه العشرين وعن اللقاء تاريخ
الذي جمع امس الرئيس صيني شيء جفينغ مع
الرئيس جو بايدن كان لقاء تاريخي كيف
تنظرون في واشنطن الى هذا اللقاء وهل من
الممكن ان هذا اللقاء حصل صدفه انه نتيجه
اتصالات غير مباشره وربما لم تصل الينا في
وسائل الاعلام وقادت الى هذا الاجتماع
اللافت امس شكرا
هذا اللقاء الثنائي بين رئيس الصيني كامل
اهم اجتماعيات لكلان في هذه الاداره نعرف
ان رئيس قائد مكان لديه الفلوس اكثر من
مره اللي يتكلم وهو يتحدث الصيني عبر
الانترنت
رئيس قائد ان هو ايران ليس هناك اي بديل
ليله دبلوماسيه
وفعلا راينا هذه الاجتماع لقاء تمديد اكثر
من ثلاث ساعات اذا نعم هون كان يناقشه بكل
الملفات والمجلات مهمه في العلاقات
الثنائيه وبعد هذه الملاشات المجلات
المجلات التعاونيه وبعد هذه مجالات لدينا
منافسه عليها واسماء ان ذلك من رئيس
بدون شكل نحن كنا في تواصل مع اجانب
الصيني منذ شهور لنكون بكل الاستعدادات
اللازمه لهذا الاجتماع
والخلافات السياسيه فيما يتعلق بعدد من
الملفات مثل كوريا الشماليه تايوان قد
يؤدي بالفعل الى صراع دوله جديده
ليس هناك اي سبب لاي من هذه الملفات
القلق لديناها حول الاي توتر عبر المنديك
تايوان او الوضع مع الكوريه الشماليه ليس
هناك اي سبب من اي من هذه الملفات
والتحديات تؤدي الى سرعه بيننا التواصل
لدينا الامكانيه في تواصل بين الولايات
المتحده وله الحكومه الصينيه وكلنا الان
امامنا هذه التحديات الاكبر تهدئه
المشتركه مثل غير مناخ كما راينا في قبل
27 في شرم الشيخ
19 وايضا الرئيسان كان يناقشان همم
التحديات بالنسبه تخفيف للاب ديون همم
لدينا كل هذه التحديات مشتركه امامنا لذلك
ان ليس هناك اي سبب اي من هذه هذه اخرى ان
تؤدي الى سرعه
صريحين هذه المره هل الهدف من هذا التقارب
الصيني الامريكي اذا صحت التسميه هو
ممارسه المزيد من الضغوط على موسكو
اذ اذا نحن لدينا علاقات مع الصين
وكان وما زال لدينا علاقه ما روسيه واا
بيكون اسف الان ليست فقط الولايات المتحده
همم والغرب التي تاخذ الموقف ضد هذه الحرب
الوحشيه التي تشنوها رئيس
كاميرا هنا في التصويت في جميع الاعمى في
الامم المتحده اكثر من 140 دوله كانت
الاساسيه الدنيا
الحاله الجديده الغير معتاده ما بين بكين
واشنطن الى اين ستقود خاصه بانتظار زياره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكان الى بكين
للممارسه المزيد من التنسيق فيما يتعلق
بالملفات الخلاف بين الدولتين
باي نتيجه
خطوه ولكن فعلا هذه الاجتماع كان اختهم
مهمه جدا لان
ليس هناك اي شيء الان لنكونن علاقات صعبه
او سرعه
العالم همم يتوق ذلك لان قائد السيئه بيني
و الولايات المتحده لا تؤثر فقط على هذه
البلديه لا تؤثر على الالم باكمالي
بالنسبه
كل هذه الملفات والتحديات الاخرى اذن بدون
هذه لما الدول
همم لذلك نعم نحن نريد ان نبني على
اجتماع المؤهلين نحن نتوقع ان الوزير
بنيكان هو سيزور الصين قريبا ليس لدينا
حتى الان التوقيت بالضبط ولكن من من
الاشهر المقبله نحن نتوقع هذه الزياره
وفعلا نحن نتطلع الى استمرار هذه المناقشه
طيب وهذا الاجتماع
مشاركه كما سمعنا بشكل واضحه من رئيس
الاندونيسي حان وقت الان لنهنوا كلنا نحن
نقوم بالتنسيق اللازم والالم يستحق ذلك
ليس فقط هذه الدول في مش مت-20 اذا من
اللازم ادعوا للقبره همم الولايات المتحده
والصين لدينا
الاكبر الاقتصاديه في العالم لدينا مثلا
نتكلم محاوله غير مناخ لدينا اكبر انباثات
الغازات في العالم
نكون همم التنسيق بين حالتين بلدين وعيدا
بين كل الدول في المجموعه
في دبي الى اي مدى تمثل هذه القمه مصدر
الراحه للرئيس خاصه بانها تاتي بعد سيطره
على مجلس الشيوخ الكل يتحدث عن ان الرئيس
دخل الى هذه القمه وهو مرتاح البال فيما
يتعلق بعدم وجود اي القبائل في تنفيذ
قراراته على الصعيد الدولي فيما تبقى من
ولايه الرئاسه اذن قناتك رسمي في الوزاره
الخارجيه انا لا اقوم بتعليق كثيرا
الانتخابات الداخليه الانتخابات المحليه
في الولايات المتحده ولكن من الممكن اؤكد
ان هي الرساله مهمه جدا ليست بنسبه
النتيجه ليس بالنسبه من سيفوز في مجلس
الشيوخ من يسيطر على مجلس الشيوخ الرساله
حول الانتخابات
لازم نكون همم لازم نتكلم حول الحاله
الوضع في ولايه المتحده نحن ليس لدينا كل
الهنود دائما 100% لازم همم نوفر للعالم
الثوره
المتهده ايضا لدينا الامكانيه للانتخابات
لك اسمح لي بسؤال اخر اخير فيما يتعلق
بممارسه الولايات المتحده وبدعم ايضا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي المزيد من الضغط على
موسكو فيما يتعلق بالحرب في اوكراني من
خلال قمه الجيتون هل بالفعل مارست
الولايات المتحده ضغوط على المشاركين في
القمه لاتخان الموقف اكثر وضوح من الازمه
في اوكرانيا اذا انا لا اريد ان تخلف في
المناقشه الدبلوماسيه داخل غرف هنا في
مجموعه 20 ولكن بدون شكل وانت متاهله
لدينا نفس القلق والناس الاهتمام حول هذه
الحرب الوحشيه بدون اي تبريه من رئيس
اوكرانيين الذي كنا لدينا من قبل الهرم
اذن من شهور قبل الحرب كنا لدينا نفس
القضاء وكنا نقوم بتحديد العالم ان نحن
نتوقع ان في نهايه المطاف بالرقم من كل
جهود الدبلوماسيه الرئيس بوت ان هو سيكون
هذا ذلك اذا لدينا نفس العهد تمام ولدينا
نفس المناقشه مع كل الدول هنا في مجموعه
العشرين وادعوا الاخرى حول اي امكانيه لان
ها هذه العرب